the mark of the games would stage here
at e3 2016 here to talk about horizon
zero dawn we've got herman and gb from
guerrilla games guys thank you so much
for joining myself and two more for what
a fantastic show you had at the sony
press conference what was it like being
able to show the game off to the world
you know last year we showed that boss
fight and this year we wanted to go in
them really just show the game the way
it plays just it actually is a part of
the game it wasn't a demo and that felt
really really good yeah you're really
going to the nitty-gritty of like moment
to moment gameplay instead of having
this one big boss fight I think a lot of
questions after the after the you know
debut were like what is what is it
beyond this amazing massive like also
kind of looking scripted boss fight but
you obviously put to rest those
questions showing that it says there's
like a massive open world you know you
have these all these options and it was
an excellent like it was one of my
highlights of the the press conference
for sure thank you thank you like this
man yeah we're already getting questions
in the chat people asking let's start
with things like all the robots all the
AIS are they all hostile so no they're
not all hostile there are more dos o
machines so for example the rosettes I
saw each other boo like creatures they
don't necessarily attack on sight if you
poke them with a stick that will surely
come after you but generally the kind of
dull cell and but the bigger ones
especially the sort of more predatorial
look at once they will attack on site
and they're very dangerous from an
aerial perspective another story we have
is kind of rediscovering what happened
to humanity but is there ever I'd like
an exploration of your impact on the
Machine animals because like you see
these animals and all other machines you
still kind of sympathize with the winner
when you're taking these docile animals
and kind of killing her more like
suffering what they're supposed to be
doing is there an exploration like of
your responsibility to nature around you
even if it is kind of disconnected
because it's machine it was funny we
Sony made this dish washer suit watchers
a little the little one that you first
encounter pretty much and they did it
behind the scenes thing so JB and I walk
in at the first thing you want to do is
pet it it was like a neat n et moment
you want to touch it and be gentle with
it
mean will we have this tendency these
days to kind of treat like machines for
example vba as if it with the same kind
of love that we would feel like a kitten
or something like that exactly like it's
kind of seeing seeing the kind of the
broad with the code broad broad hats for
ya when you kind of take over it and and
kind of mount it and that kind of thing
I was like oh man that sucks like i hope
i hope that think it's gonna be alright
and when you fight I mean this a few
hostile enemies which is fine but like
there's a few dots our enemies that kind
of trap and kind of you scavenge and use
for resources that were kind of pulling
at my heartstrings even though I didn't
expect it which is it any interesting AO
is very respectful of nature and of the
machine so she doesn't feel like she's
just killing him for killing sake she's
after the resources she needs it but
yeah it's a function she's andres but in
a way that respects it pre one of the
things I really appreciate was when you
were attacking an enemy she kind of you
hear her speaking and saying like I
really need the resources before she
starts doing that is that something that
happens like throughout the game is she
always knowing it so there is a certain
amount of self talk to also bakey bring
the story across but for the demo
purposes of course there was a little
bit of extra talked and also explained
what was going on okay I know it's a
this conversation options is there kind
of do they affect how the game plays out
it was a major difference or is it just
kind of more of a slight change more
like slices just more like talking to
people in real life you're not changing
the world by having a conversation but
there are life and death situations
bakey deck you can impact by fire
dialogue the main thing that we want to
do with the dialogue is that it's a form
of exploration you're exploring the
rules via dialogue and you're exploring
a lawyer character and the other
characters around you as well you could
pick up quest side quests in the
dialogue as well stepping back a bit
like you guys are like one of the most
exciting things about and I think the
reason why people like talk to it so
quickly was because you guys are known
as the kill zone studio the first person
shooter studio this is so far different
from what we expected from you guys like
maybe everyone's thinking look at a
different type of shooter from gorilla
this is such a you know a pivot for you
guys when did you come up with this and
how confident were you that you could
pull this off going into it was it a
case of like learning as you go along or
where you kind of
confident that you had the skill set to
create an open world action game a bit
of everything there we we started after
we completed Killzone 3 that was in 2011
it's been a long project been working
this for quite a while and and obviously
we're building on what we learned and
killzone there's a tactical combat there
there's obviously the creating of
gorgeous worlds of what we're after but
at the same time it is our first open
world game it's a first world that that
had Cesc quests in it so we we did hire
some very bespoke teams we hired a
writing team with experience in this
genre quest designers and all of that is
new to the studio right until one of
interesting things coming from forever
computers and understanding combat
really deeply in common spaces really
deeply sort of helps us to also deliver
a new experience to the RPG genre and
how deep is the RPG genre I mean I've
seen them interview footage like you
know there's some damage count stuff
like that how deep does that go so it's
not very heavily stats based it's not
baby that every plus/minus where the
only weapons busy really matters it's
more broader strokes but the real
opportunity is more in the character
progression so being able to build her
up there's a skill tree there there's
dialogue options of course there's a
lots piggy to do what your character in
this world I'm interested how you
balance that kind of the scavenging
element of it you're trying to you know
gather resources and create stuff with
and people in games traditionally you
kind of get dissatisfaction you portray
that satisfaction but you know
increasing damage numbers so you know
you scavenge you get this thing you
build a better gun and then you see that
your numbers are higher it doesn't look
like you're trying to do that so how do
you kind of you know really emphasize
that scavenging is important in this
game well one part is ready that's
you're building up your weapons but a
large part is actually sort of learning
and studying maggie is not just the
experience of your character but its
experience of you as a player that
really matters by learning their
behaviors analyzing them scanning the
robots find their weak spots finding the
right tools to deal with them and
getting ever better at defeating them
right let's talk a little bit about the
other human characters that halo is
going to come in contact with so it
seems like she's she's an outside and
wants to find out like why that happened
to her
who are the people who aren't you know
aren't being nice to her who are the
people who she's kind of up against
butting heads with well she's an outcast
out of a very specific tribe right and
in the trailer that we released last
week the week before she's looked after
by this gentleman a very gentle man that
that basically adopted her he's an
outcast as well and and so that tribe
kind of his her initial reference but
there are other tribes and it's a little
early to talk too much about the other
humans in the game because that they'll
come over the coming months but is there
anything else we want to talk about that
for now I think because he is an outcast
she's not necessarily that's culturally
embedded in the Nora type for a secure
versity was raised so that sort of makes
her more of an explorer somebody maybe
that has a different point of view and
is willing to accept different points of
view in the rest of the world as well
and I would add that she said there's a
lot of of myth and legend and lore
within these tribes and you you know
were just talking about the dialogue
system through exploring that you find
out that she's very much a practical
person she challenges though those myths
they're out there and she she's very
practical she's down to earth and and so
she's not she's kind of in the try but
kind of outside too she really you do
play as her as a separate person how
much how long has she been kind of out
cost and separated from the fret because
I'm wondering he shot from from birth
okay so so they could so exploring the
world she's almost discovering it in
terms of the different cultures in the
same way that the player is right yeah
the world of the North type itself for
sukkos races a little bit of an
isolationist stripe they don't really
venture out it don't talk to other
tribes I have their own culture they
have their own religion so first of all
leaving the tripe and then going out
outside it basically gets different
points of views and also of course a lot
of Legends and Mitch myths about how the
world came to be like this and every
tribe has their take on it and some of
them are complete crap others are
basically he might have a hint of truth
even so maybe looking through that and
talking to people on exploring at you
get to learn a little bit about how this
wolf will fit together this also the
mention of demons yes all about so it
seems like you've got so many warring
factions here what we had
demons face see the the machines in the
game they're they're animalistic looking
right there all inspired by some animals
except for that corruptor that you see
on the screen right now Annie Laurie
actually doesn't know machines like that
she encounters them but she's unfamiliar
with them and these are the corruptors
their dear kind of old-world machines
that are unknown to her ok so I mean in
terms of the world itself in the
trailers you know there was a
civilization that came before that maybe
got two great collapsed in on itself and
our nature so well back is it definitely
kind of like based on humanities it is
right now is it an alternate kind of
world I mentioned no its humanity right
it is humanity yeah it is us and where
exactly this is we were not really
revealing yet oh yeah oh the internet
Peggy has made some good guesses some
screen uh like frame by frame these
methods also makes a lot of guesses yeah
they make us always good it must be
great to see that happening though even
if it's kind of off base to see that
you've clearly thought or create this
world that is resonating enough for
people to want to stop and look at a
frame-by-frame especially as you know
working on our and that kind of stuff
that must be like super satisfying
Talia's a really fun baby just going
through the forums and medical people
idolize you can bunk by frame and then
sometimes getting it right and often
getting it completely wrong but it's fun
but you seeing there fairies question
from the chat they're asking are we
gonna be able to visit any of the cities
like the broken-down cities from before
or is it all going to be wilted ass
based gameplay it's a Seema's open-world
game you can go anywhere and go through
the mountain tops you can go to the
rivers you can explore the city's the
villages the settlements interior spaces
Wow everything very impressive and in
terms of like building a world outside
of outside of the game have you thought
about that whether you want to explore
it in stuff like comics or like you know
books novels that's the kind of thing
that everyone is doing now everyone with
a world wants to exploit the world and
build it with outside of it so go or
we're very focused on finishing this one
really good first and I'm Maggie I'm
sure whether he will explore lots of
different ways of you doing things with
this universe but it's a great at it
will take it back to that awesome yeah
I'll tell everyone i'm down for comics
well time is big oh yeah
dude so I'm always looking forward to
and multiplayer like have you thought
about it yeah I mean Killzone had
perhaps overlooked multiplayer like it's
it had is amazing few modes like and and
more people should probably have
borrowed from some of them but have you
thought about maybe bringing some what
my player stuff people we think about a
lot of different things but right
decided very clearly that arising zero
dollars going to be a single player game
right so I'm going to stick with that
and that's it is already a new IP for us
it's in a new genre there's so much noon
is that a studio should take on before
blowing itself up so we decided to just
keep it at singing player for them in
terms of the creature design ops ii am
very heavily influenced by real live
creatures what kind of artistic
liberties can you take with them can you
sort of sea creatures in real life and
think well if I'm making a robot version
i might do this or add this yeah whether
there is so big it as of course
requirements from the designers what
they want to see and some cases very
come up with really outrageous ideas
sometimes I work sometimes it doesn't
what's been the craziest thing that
someone said no to uh I don't make my
ski we've said knows of anything yet
very tricky um we had Tsubaki let a
couple of them go maybe they were a
little bit too ambitious Bob Iggy we've
got a very good selection of the current
machines in the game so the big boss
fight that we saw at the press
conference and then multiple ways to
take down that one enemy what I mean is
that kind of like it do you have to have
all those weapons going in to be able to
take it down can you take it down with
like complete bare bones or do you have
to have that's a ton of different
options out there I mean it's the
attacks on it it's got that arm that for
its kind of a long range close combat if
you will the signature tech I would say
is that jump on you write it also used
the environment throwing rocks you can
play with the Cheetahs a number of
things that you could do more off
Frances and replace it by some of the
things she's got the the explosive traps
but there's things like like tripwire
you can use you can have multiple kind
of long range too there's so many a ton
of different options everybody the
studio plays it it's got their own style
of playing it's never the same I've seen
it played a couple of times on the stage
for goodbyes are alcoholics and everyone
deals that are differently
and some of them have become really sort
of graceful where they're sliding
underneath its legs and jumping over it
does it look whoa I think we've got one
QA guy that can actually play it exactly
the way was recorded at for the sony
press conference but JB and I couldn't
do it exactly like that nor do we want
to it's very require skill um the
dishonored guys say that when they've
been played testing and seeing people
play people come up with unexpected
things that they didn't anticipate with
all the systems working together have
you guys accounted that at all emerged
in game design wow what is the best item
you can anticipate the merchants game
design that's where I is emerging about
of course where you can require a lot of
fix ourselves maybe we do start playing
with the systems and then make s
programs to change it a little bit to
make something weird and fantastical
possible right but i would give us an
example we have some of these grazers in
there they have the canisters on the
back there explode explodable explosives
proper English here but now it's kind of
become a running thing for us to get a
hurt together and shoot the guy know and
then boom boom they all go off and
that's not something that was designed
as such but it just that is one of the
funnest thing to do right guys thank you
so much when can we get our hands on
horizon zero dawn it's going to be held
here in the US on the twenty-eighth of
februari next year wonderful thank you
so much for joining us and of course for
more coverage from this year's e3 make
sure you keep your eyes peeled to
gamespot com
you